I was there while I was like really
falling in love with with my wife yeah
you heard that right Justin long just
called Kate Bosworth his wife and I feel
very lucky yeah it's a good time Justin
revealed that he and his fiance tied the
knot during the May 9th episode of his
podcast life is short recalling how he
fell in love with his now wife while
they were shooting their horror film
Barbarian in Bulgaria oh God
thank you
and Kate she seemingly confirms the news
wearing what looked like a wedding band
with her engagement ring during an
Amazon live with her man on Monday
UT has reached out to the couple's Reps
for comment
back in March a source confirmed the
couple was engaged after Kate flashed a
whole lot of bling on that finger at the
Vanity Fair Oscars after party at the
time E.T Source said the two were
thrilled to be getting married they make
an amazing couple and they're so excited
I had gotten to a place I had anyway
where I possibly comfortable I was
comfortable with myself I was ready to
be I didn't know it at the time but I
was ready for the one and the one
uh I met I found the pair confirmed the
news in April on Instagram just in
posting this snap alongside a lengthy
caption which teased Kate's appearance
on his podcast to talk about their newly
engaged status adding I cherish the days
we've had and the ones to come and Kate
she shared the sweet news too writing if
life is short find the one who brings
you endless peace and radical wonder I
am so grateful it's you
he like really looked at me and he said
um to spend my life with you and I said
I smiled and I said well yeah you have
you have that oh my gosh you have that
and he said no I mean I I really want to
spend my life with you yeah no
for real
yeah yeah it was the easiest the words
just came out like so naturally the
lovebirds first connected on the set of
House Of Darkness back in 2021
and then they kiss and he's never kissed
before that August Kate announced she
and her husband of eight years Michael
polish were calling it quits she'd
actually filed for divorce a month
earlier and last month the couple who
have been pretty private about their
love opened up about their happily ever
after I love you so much and so you're
we're going to spend our lives together
yeah so so what do you what do you guys
call a hot scoop yeah so hot scoop um
she said yes
[Music]
okay